Yes!
Hi!
Welcome.
So my name is Jan Jongboom.
I indeed live in the
Netherlands.
It took me 14 hours on an airplane without
inflight entertainment
to get down here.
So sacrifices, you know?
I work in Telenor, it's like AT&T.
We're a big Telco, and they pay me to work
on Open Source.
So yes.
Thank you.
So in the past two and a half years, I've
been mostly working with Mozilla.
I've been a pair on the Firefox OS project,
we've launched phones in Eastern
Europe and southeast Asia, and lately I've
been focusing my efforts on
anything related with the real world.
Internet of things, robots, yesterday I
even built a rocket.
Come on.
Yes, it went up extremely fast, and it went
down
even faster.
But...
You know, like...
The fact that we're in this incredible ballroom
with
so many developers, that are all getting excited
by playing with bots, playing
with rockets, playing with ships -- that excites
me, man.
Because...
It is one
of the best times to be in technology at this
moment.
We are on the verge of a
new era.
When I learned to program, like, in the '90s,
if you wrote an
application, if you wrote a computer program,
it essentially meant that, like,
it's running in this confined box.
If there's input getting into the computer,
you did it over your keyboard, and then when
it came out, it came out of this.
This is no longer the case.
Like, the new programmer is going to do this,
like, having a button and then, like, hello,
Jan -- it's going to do it with a
real breadboard and a button and an LED that
flashes.
You cannot imagine how
incredibly happy I was, after I got my Arduino
starter kit, and I wrote some
code that made an LED blink.
You know?
I was like this.
Like, showing my mom.
Like, hey, mom.
You can type in your name in a computer and
it spits your name
back out.
And I have not been as enthusiastic as this
about computers in a
long time.
And finally, doing all these hardware things,
that is what gets me totally
into this.
So we can take our code out of this confined
box, and into the real
world.
And this is a revolution that is just getting
started.
We're nowhere
near yet.
We don't know what is going on, or how it's
going to end up.
But,
like, looking at all these extremely smart
people, one thing I know for sure
-- that this revolution is going to be led
by JavaScript.
I can imagine you
guys are also incredibly tired.
Like, three days of, like, full on action.
So today we're going to have, like, a fun,
nice demo-full talk.
We're going to
have audience participation.
Yes, real audience participation.
Isn't that
cool?
And we're going to have a fuckton of GIFs.
So...
All right!
Okay.
So the
first thing that I want to talk to you about
today is computer-generated
music.
A lot of the music that we listen to today
is, for a smaller or bigger
part, is really kind of coming out of a computer.
Like, your drum loops might
be recorded.
You might sing something in, and then add
effects to it on your
PC.
There's, like, a group of people that take
this one step further.
And that's people that do Algoraves.
For me, this is the nerdiest thing, but it's
like...
Nerds are taking over the world.
Like, really.
Like...
A computer guy,
standing in front of an audience, like, live
coding, and people start dancing
towards that?
Man, shit, that's...
Poom!
So three years ago, Alex McLean
started this movement, and last year at JSConf
Asia, I met a PhD from UCSB,
Charlie Roberts, who made JavaScript environments
for Algoravers.
And it's an
online IDE with a DSL that allows you to write
code and, like, make people
dance to that.
It's like for electronic music.
So let's say I want to make a
beat.
All I need to do is -- A is drums.
And then just a beat.
Put it a little
bit up.
That's basic.
Pretty cool.
It took me six years or something to get
this out of a normal drum kit.
And I can do it with one line of JS.
We can
also add a little pitch to it.
So you can play around with variables.
Pretty cool.
There's a lot more you can do.
Like Vocoding.
For example, here
is...
Like, our own JSConf song.
JSConf.
(robot voices saying JSConf in various pitches
over and over again
rhythmically)
Now, if you look closely at this, you can
see there is a whole number of
variables in this code.
And these are parameters that directly influence
the
music.
If you set the pitch of the drum, you get,
like, an actual different
sound.
Like, for programmers, this is amazing.
You know?
If you're standing
there in front of an audience, you can play
around with the parameters.
Nothing is very static.
Once you pick one, that's basically it.
That's what
it's going to be.
Then I thought...
What else do you see at concerts these
days?
Like, way too much...
Mobile phones.
And mobile phones are now pretty good at,
like, capturing what's happening
around you, because mobile phones have sensors,
sensors, sensors, and sensors.
So...
Today we're going to do a nice little experiment,
where you guys are
going to help me produce some music.
Because we're going to use the sensor
data of all your phones...
And I have no clue how many phones my computer
is
going to be able to handle.
It'll all get uploaded to a node.js server,
and
then we feed the data from all of you together
into a music generating
algorithm.
So you guys have influence over how the music
is going to sound
today.
If you want to play around with this later
or if you are a cool Algoraver,
this code is on Github, so you can integrate
it.
So instead of set variable
for the pitch, we can get the yaw or the pitch
of all your phones, and then
feed that into the algorithm.
So when people start moving around the phones,
music will actually change.
Here's a variable.
Okay.
This is one of the demos
we're going to do today.
Another one...
Because your mobile phone is still
really confined by what the sensor can detect.
Gyrometer or accelerometer.
But
Bluetooth beacons -- I have a few here.
They're tiny chips.
They don't run
JavaScript, but they just broadcast their
existence.
I can put one on the wall
and for the next two years, it will just say...
Hey, I'm here, I'm here, I'm
here, I'm here.
They're getting tiny.
This is the new estimation.
They go for
$10.
Tiny, small, you can broadcast a value like
a URL or sensor values.
Now, the cool thing is that the ability to
detect beacons, to walk into a room
and see -- okay, there's ten around you in
five meters -- is coming to
JavaScript.
We actually finished implementing this in
Firefox OS and hope to
bring it to Firefox for Android on short notice.
After June it's going to be
accessible.
So we have phones that run this and I'll do
some demos for that.
How do you scan for beacons?
It's straightforward.
The most Bluetooth thing is
not standardized yet, but in the web Bluetooth
standards, we're talking about
implementing low energy support for Bluetooth.
So this is coming to the
standards track.
We can get the adapter, start a low energy
scan.
We're not
interested in all the devices around us.
And then when a device is found, we
get an event.
A couple seconds later, we can stop.
The event you get contains
a scan record.
And that basically is all the data you send
it.
Most things currently follow the iBeacon standards
from Apple, and that gives
you three IDs, essentially.
A UUID for a manufacturer, a major, and a
minor.
So that's how you can detect which beacon
is what.
Now, what are we going to
do with this today?
The JavaScript baby monitor.
So you're going to tag a baby
with a phone.
Then on the phone, we run some JavaScript
that constantly
searches around for the beacons.
Then based on how strong the signal is, we're
going to triangulate from the three beacons
with some math, and that way we
know where in the room the baby is located.
Now, you might think...
Tagging a
baby with a phone -- is that really necessary,
Jan?
At JSConf EU I presented a
project called Jan OS that allows you to rip
apart the main board of your
phone and tag your baby with that.
So you can make a child-friendly device.
I'm not going to talk about that today.
Let's see what this looks like.
We
have a baby.
We position three beacons around it.
And then we tag the baby with the
chipboard.
Now...
We basically know how far from the beacon
we are, because we
get signal strength.
So if we combine the data from three beacons,
we realize
that where these intersect, that is where
the baby has to be.
And then, when
the baby runs away, then we can start doing
alarm.
Pretty simple, right?
All
on JavaScript.
So...
Demo time.
If you're on the JSConf track A Wi-Fi network,
then get yourself over to 192.168.157.18,
port 9321.
Because that is where the
magic is going to happen.
So...
What you're going to see on your screen is
essentially a dot.
And this dot is getting influenced by the
way you rotate
your phone in physical space.
So I'm going to go to my command center.
So here we have all the people.
We
have ten people connected, and we're getting
the data from all the phones.
Averaging it.
(mid-tempo beat)
And the way you pitch it.
And we can make some music.
So if you hold your
phone like this, we should be able to go exactly
in the center.
And now I want
to move it like to the left top corner.
So change your phone in physical space
to the left top corner.
(beat pitch distorts)
There's so many people connected now.
One person is doing it.
Get over
there, and see how the music changes.
(beat pitch bends downward)
You feel how the music changes a little bit?
Depending how high or how low
the thing is, we have echoing and pitch.
And it's always hard to do audience
participation in this thing.
It's crazy, right?
So my server is completely
going berserk on this.
(drum machine beat continues)
I can show how to works with just one person.
Because this is totally not
how I thought it would work.
So I'm connecting myself to my own network.
And...
Then go to the page.
Okay.
So now it's just me.
And when I move it...
(bass distorts)
You can get pretty rad effects out of this
(pitch of bass distorts)
And at some point you can echo it so it starts
beeping.
It's not fun for
anyone.
Now, we can also do this with visuals.
So now, when I move it...
(erratic rhythm)
So based on how high the thing is, the BPM
is dependent.
So now it's nice
and relaxing.
If you move it all the way over here...
It changes how the music
feels.
(rhythm accelerates)
With all these people, it would go better,
but it was more than it could...
Now we have BPM.
But we can add some extra magic to it.
So here's the code we
have.
Let's go full screen.
Essentially what we can just write is...
Like, get
a drum sequence, then the amplitude is, like,
based on data that we get from
the phone, and the BPM is based on other data
that we get from the phone.
Now,
I made a thing that parses a GIF and can dynamically
change the speed of the
GIF based on how fast the music is playing.
(mellow drum machine beat)
Now I like it a little slower.
Or we can go completely crazy.
(beat accelerates)
All right.
So that was the music.
I'm going to let the music play a bit.
And then I'm going to set up...
My beacons.
So let's say that this is the
area.
(stopping music)
So let's say this is the area where the baby
is allowed to go.
So I'm
putting a light blue beacon here.
I measured this before.
It's a bit over 3
meters, which is in United States measurements
I think 81.4 stones.
(laughter)
So we have three here.
And now...
Let's go to that page.
So this is where
the data is going to come in.
So I'm going to put the phone here.
Just to make
sure that we're getting the data.
And...
Zoom out a little.
Whenever the data
is now coming in, it will redraw.
So we're connected.
And data should start
flowing in.
So as you can see, the...
How big the circle is depends on where I
position the phone.
So now we're just waiting for the data from
the main
beacon, which is the one here.
It really varies at this point.
And it's
because we get, like, the raw value, and the
raw value is really dependent on
a lot of factors.
So we can buffer.
And then it will slowly remove all the
drift, and we get a better positioning.
We can also draw the intersections.
And based on that, we can get the average.
So if I move the phone or baby...
To, for example, here...
You can see that,
like, the actual position that we detect is
actually getting there.
If I start
moving the thing around, luckily enough, babies
are not very fast.
So it's
okay if it takes a couple of seconds.
So I'm moving it here.
Then you'll see
that the position of the orange dots will
start to change.
We cannot do this
-- if the baby gets out of the bounding box,
then if the baby gets out of the
bounding box, we can sound an alarm or do
something about it.
So we're here.
And now you see it like...
You see it moving towards the purple one.
Now, I
figured -- like, okay, that's pretty cool.
But what if you could listen to
baby-generated music?
So...
We're going to open the baby thing.
And we're going to apply the data
that we get out of here, like, the position
of the baby in physical space, and
feed that into a music generating algorithm.
(discordant beats)
So the idea is that whenever the baby is in
this space where it's allowed
to go, everything is all right.
We don't really have to play big-ass crazy
music.
Have we got a visual on the thing?
Okay.
But now what if the baby
starts to escape?
You know?
That would be disturbing.
For some reason it
doesn't work yet.
So I'm going to restart the application with
the phone.
So
when the baby escapes, we can change the BPM
of the music a lot.
So we need to
check out something.
Crazy stuff is happening.
So here we go.
(BPM gets slower)
So relaxed...
And...
Let's see if I run away fast enough...
If you can...
Having technical...
The mint one just stopped working.
Go, go, go, go.
If
necessary, just go to the pizza guy.
(BPM stays the same tempo) (BPM increases
rapidly)
Music!
Fast!
We need to act on this shit now!
Thank you!
(BPM continues to accelerate)
All right.
Let me close that thing off and get back to
my slides.
(music turns off)
Now, we have ten more minutes, you know?
And I figured I always wanted,
like, a real one more thing moment.
Um...
So, I mean, I've been working on
Firefox OS on a variety of platforms.
Now we're focusing on the internet of
things.
The thing is, Firefox OS is not just about
phones anymore.
It's
televisions.
Things that can run on it.
We also want to bridge the gap to the
physical space.
And for that, we invested in a number of technologies,
including Bluetooth low energy, virtual reality,
with Firefox VR, but also web
CL, which allows you to get a video stream
and start detecting stuff on that.
And from that premise, we started thinking
about -- what if we would design a
wearable running Mozilla technology?
And we figured that the beacon stuff
would be incredibly useful.
Because if we -- for $3 can get, like, a beacon
straight from the factory, and tag that at,
like, interesting places, or tag
it to people, it would allow us to, like,
augment your reality, like, based on
where you physically are in the world.
Walking around.
Of course, this also
has to be built on open standards.
And today you guys are going to see the
very, very, very first wearable that Mozilla
has been working on.
Like, right
here on JSConf, like, a couple minutes before
the end.
Pretty exciting.
So the
first wearable that we together, like, with
Mozilla and a bunch of partners
have built, is...
Mozilla Glass.
And I got it with me, actually, here today.
So...
We looked at, like, what
other wearables are around at this point.
And we had, like, a number of things
that we required.
So first of all, we wanted to work any type
of glasses.
Prescription or sunglasses.
It doesn't really matter.
The prototype that we
have here is mounted on the glasses that you
got in your goodie bag.
It's the
Availity track?
What the company is called?
And the glasses were from the same
brand.
We also want that to be a standalone product.
No extra device required.
There's voice control to get, like, information
without always looking at your
screen.
And the self-build kit is going for about
$300 US.
Are you ready?
(cheering)
All right.
First thing.
Mozilla Glass.
Hand built by me.
So what we see
here...
And I've got one with me.
We're going to demonstrate in a sec.
We have
a camera module on top.
On the left, we have the display and sensors.
These
two talk with each other over a web RTC connection
to get the data from the
camera into your corner.
And then we have a small little mirror in
the inner
side of your glasses, so you can look a bit
to the right and get your image
from the display on the left.
All right.
So...
For this, for this next
segment, I need to have Steve, Jacob, and
Chris on stage, because they're
going to help me with this thing.
So guys, run up, run up, run up.
All right.
Where the hell are my beacons?
Oh, here.
Oh, you're going to be Chris
Williams.
Okay.
So I need you guys to, like, okay.
What we're going to do
is...
It's like a party.
You know?
Here.
And I want to know who do I have to
talk to at parties?
You know?
I want to be, like, the cool guy that always
knows the subject to talk about and people
think you're interesting.
What are
we going to do today?
Let's say we tag all these people with beacons.
Steve
gets ice, Jacob gets blueberry, and you get
mint.
And I need you to be
socially awkward and stand by yourself at
a party.
Not too close to each
other, please.
Yeah, a bit...
Like, near the stage, please.
I'm going to go to...
So the
beautiful thing is...
Because of the web RTC that gets the camera,
we can also
get a live feed here of the screen.
Go there.
Mozilla Glass.
As you can see,
we're not connected to anything here.
I am going to come here.
This is going
to be my camera client.
Huh?
So...
Here we go.
And...
Here we've got the
glasses.
Let me just verify that we're still connected.
Yeah.
You know,
hardware is a lot of fun.
I'm so hoping that on Twitter people will
go
completely crazy.
Like Mozilla introduces a wearable!
So we're connected.
I don't see any beacons yet, but that is going
to come.
I'm going to place this on my head.
I'm going to connect to my camera module
here.
So...
I ran out of duct tape.
The moment that I connect to this
thing...
We should start seeing a video stream here.
Okay.
So here we are.
Now, of course, we have voice controls as
well.
And for...
Ah, wait.
That
is...
So we have voice control as well.
We partnered with Andreas Gal, the CTO
of Mozilla, to do the voicing.
I wanted Brendan Eyck, but he said ask Taylor
Swift.
Did you guys get a stream here?
Okay.
So let me full screen this thing.
Yeah.
That's pretty hard to see with these glasses
on.
(laughter)
Oh.
Okay.
So...
Back to the thing.
Okay.
So here we are.
Back.
On the
stream.
Need to have some sensor data out of here
as well.
That would be nice.
Because now I can ask my voice assistant to
come on stage.
Hello, Andreas.
Can
you introduce yourself?
Hello from Mozilla Glass.
I am Andreas Gau, CTO of Mozilla.
Because we of course also care about other
companies that are working in
the same space, like Google...
We have...
Sorry.
Now I really need to get some
assistance.
I mean, I can say...
Andreas, call me Google.
Okay, Google.
Isn't that nice?
All right.
Can you start the...
Fuuu...
This...
You know,
this worked so well in my head.
(laughter)
Need a hand?
Yeah.
Okay.
So...
You can hold them yourself.
So we're going to get the
video stream back at this point.
I mean, it looks pretty good on you, to be
honest.
Okay.
So...
Now, let's do the augmented reality thing.
And I want you
to walk over there.
Where do you have the beacon?
So...
This is supposed to
be...
Okay.
So get a bit closer.
You need to be in close proximity.
We're at a
party here.
So whenever this works, this is, like, always
a good thing, to
have a backup Glass.
Not mounted.
Like real glasses.
So here we go.
Steve
Kinney!
Information!
This is augmented reality, guys!
Now...
And as you can see, the moment that we
walk away, immediately the information disappears
as well, and we can do the
same thing with Jacob here.
I was hoping somebody would come talk to me.
That would be nice.
So what can we talk about with you today?
Hey, man.
How is it going with you?
Hey, Jacob.
We could talk about the Cure.
Or if we can talk to Chris Williams...
Everyone knows him.
Hey, hey, Chris.
What should I do with the drone battery?
Oh, you know like...
Oh, hey.
Hi, it's me, Chris Williams.
I just thought I should mention that
you might want to not put that drone battery
in your checked luggage.
Uh...
(applause)
All right!
So it can also tell you based on the voice
commands who you're
near.
Will do.
You're not near anyone.
I'm not near anyone.
And this is the coolest feature.
It will also shoot
laser beams.
I'm sorry, Jan.
I'm afraid I can't do that.
Okay.
So...
Here's the thing.
We cannot predict the future.
You know?
It's
2015.
Where the hell is my hoverboard?
Actually, after, like, yesterday's
event with the nodecopters, we decided we
no longer want hoverboards.
We want
quad copters or drones that can carry people.
We can't predict the future.
But
one thing we know for sure.
And I hope that today's demonstration, even
though
it was a bit flaky at times, is like a demonstration
of that.
And like the
whole JSConf thing -- and this is the thing
that you have to take home from
all of this -- we can't predict the future.
But we do know that a large part
of that is going to be written in JavaScript.
And with that, my 30 minutes are
up, and I really, really want to thank you
all for being here.
And thanks for
such a great conference!